- [Narrator] This is a
giant praying mantis.
It's located here, in Las Vegas, Nevada.
But it's not located on the strip,
the place that most people
think of when they think Vegas.
Today, we're venturing off the beaten path
with the help of three people.
- Hi.
- [Narrator] To three places
that are single-handedly
keeping Vegas weird.
This is Tim Arnold.
He's the director of stuff and things
at the Pinball Hall of Fame in Las Vegas.
- Pinball Hall of Fame is
an old auto parts store
with a bunch of pinball machines
we dug out of dumpsters.
No, no, no, it's a marvelous museum
full of antique treasures that have been
lovingly restored to
their original condition
that we actually let the
public come in and play.
We have games from the '30s
on up to today's modern games.
I've seen people walking down an aisle
full of pinball machines
and they'll stop dead.
The first time I kissed a girl was,
I was playing that game, and I
can't believe it's here again!
This is not something
that can be digitized
and sent down the pipes on the internet.
This is something that only
exists in the real world
and the only place to play it is here.
- [Narrator] Okay, Tim, we're sold.
Who's got change for a dollar?
- My name's Kristine Reynolds.
- [Narrator] She's the general manager
at Downtown Container Park.
- Which is completely made
of shipping containers!
We wanted to re-use materials instead
of just building from scratch.
Container Park prides
itself on helping out
Mom and Pop-type of brands.
- [Narrator] Their unusual
shops, like Kappa Toys,
which specializes in throwback toys.
And there's exceptional
grub to be had, too.
And let's not forget about the mantis.
And this guy, who makes her move.
Our last stop in downtown Las Vegas
is a totally novel, literary adventure.
- I am Drew Cohen.
My husband and I own The
Writer's Block together,
so you could say we're a
Pop and Pop establishment.
We have a lot of kooky installations
and objects in the store.
We have an antique letter press from 1890.
We have a machine called
Bearsho who will produce
a haiku on demand for 25 cents.
We have a mailbox that
belongs to the king pigeon,
and you can leave a
question in an envelope
and return in one week for your answer.
- [Narrator] And it all goes to support
free writing classes for local students.
So there you have it.
Three delightfully strange places
you can only find off
the beaten path in Vegas.
- This city is a very eccentric one.
You can encounter a lot of really
wacko and awesome businesses
if you are willing to
venture out a little bit.
- [Kristine] If you want to
do shopping, there's shopping.
The night life here is amazing.
- It really is something you
can't see in your hometown,
and that's the definition
of why you come to Vegas.
It has dancing fountains
and pinball museums
and all sorts of goofy stuff.
- [Narrator] So next time you're in Vegas,
try straying from the strip.